uh now we mentioned earlier that this of
course is the labour party's virtual
conference
weekend we spoke to sakir stamo at last
year's event things were quite different
not only could people gather in person
in brighton but jeremy corbyn was still
the party's leader one thing that is the
same as last year though is that we're
joined by len mccluskey the general
secretary of unite one of the most
powerful figures
in the labour movement thank you very
much for being honest
um i just want to start off with
coronavirus you know quite an alarming
you know warning from
the house secretary there about the
second wave and
jobs in particular because of course the
job retention scheme was protected so
many jobs throughout coronaviruses
in the process of ending being wound
down
how worried are you about what that's
going to mean for unemployment
deeply worried i mean the clock is
ticking and
the fact of the matter is that there are
millions and millions of workers
currently on the job protection scheme
who
will be worried them and their families
deeply worried about
the future what angers me
our members our workers in the uk will
be having sleepless nights
but they won't be having sleepless
nights in germany in france
and spain and belgium and holland and
scandinavia because their governments
have stepped up to the place
to protect their workforce and
my simple question to the prime minister
and to the chancellor is why should
british workers
be treated as second-class citizens in
europe
we must protect jobs in order to make
certain
that when we come out of this virus
which we which we will
we will have a robust economy with
skills still preserved with experienced
workers
able to compete otherwise this prime
minister will preside
over the highest record
unemployment figures and record poverty
levels in the uk that we've never seen
since
what jobs are you what job losses are
you predicting then well
literally if the floor is pulled from
beneath the job retention scheme we're
looking at millions
and what we have to say and what we have
been saying to
the chancellor back when he introduced
the scheme
i think i was the first to say it was
bold and courageous
and he's going to lose all of that
advantage if we don't do
something now extending the scheme like
germany have extended it for two years
at the same time though you know you're
talking there about the government needs
to step up to the plate otherwise and
you know it will be judged but at the
same time the scheme has cost
35 billion pounds this is a lot of money
obviously jobs are so important nobody
wants to see job losses
but how much longer can it continue for
as long as it takes would we sooner
those
workers costing the taxpayer 35 million
billion pound by drawing benefits on the
dole
if germany and the rest of europe can do
it why
can't our governments the truth of the
matter is that
our economy it's essential that we are
robust enough
when we come out of this virus germany
uh france they won't be looking at
wastelands in their economy but we're in
danger
of becoming wasteland uk we have to
protect jobs because without it
then the devastation that we've seen so
far will be
uh will increase uh incredibly uh
macaulay john creek said that you've
asked the prime minister for a meeting
you've written a letter they replied
not yet but i i only wrote uh earlier in
the week and so
it's been quite busy he's been busy yes
okay um
now matt hancock was also outlining um
some new uh plans
on people who need to self-isolate part
of that of course is the stick the fines
but some of it is a carrot as well this
idea that people will receive a 500
pound payment if they're on low incomes
if they
have they can't work from home is that
something you welcome of course
anything is welcome to protect workers
but of course what the chancellor needs
to do is be much more focused we need
sectoral financial packages for aviation
automotive aerospace hospitality all of
whom are in
really really trouble the government
introduced schemes to
lend money to companies through the bank
of england
it failed miserably because of the
criteria project birch was another
approach that they took to my knowledge
there's only one
company that's uh passed the criteria
the government needs to be far more
proactive and
far more imaginative than they currently
are
um now we spoke to sukhoi star morelia
in the programme
you of course didn't back him for the
leadership race but what do you make of
how he's done so far
i do back here now he's our leader uh
he's being
competent i mean i think everybody uh
putting politics to one side when they
see him
um in question time with the prime
minister the competence
of uh kia stoma really exposes
uh the prime minister so i think he's
uh he's doing okay obviously he needs to
move on in terms of the um policies
uh and the vision and you say move on
that's quite interesting isn't it
because you know he's unveiled his new
slogan
new leadership i mean it's not very
subtle is it it's a bit of a dig at
jeremy corbyn
well it's certainly got not got my
pulses running
new leadership actually it's a bit
meaningless although
uh it's a statement of fact there is a
new leader
and that new leader was elected by the
way by
uh quite overwhelmingly by our
membership including my members
on a 10-point um platform
which was a radical progressive platform
and i think i spoke to here very
recently and he was making the point
that he doesn't want to lay out
all the details of what he or labour
stands for
four years away from a general election
i can understand that but i think he
knows that fairly
soon he will have to emerge
to the public with what his vision is
and i'm
confident if he sticks to that radical
alternative that
he ran on i'm confident that that will
uh
save him well certainly in our red wall
seats it's interesting isn't it uh you
know
you're reminding us of the radical
platform that he ran
on and you know you said you know last
month uh that you know he
ran on a radical program some might say
a corbin program he has to recognize
that if the ship is he's sailing if it
lists too much to the right
it will go under are you worried that he
is moving
too far away from what you would
describe as the radical
corbyn agenda no i'm not worried at the
moment are you sure
i'm not worried at the moment but of
course we will uh
review the situation keira is in a great
great position there is real
a real wish to support him from all
wings of the labour party i mean if you
if you look at the left of the party and
how they have behaved
to care uh it's in stark contrast to the
way the right wing of the party behave
towards corbyn
so i want him to be the prime minister
next time there's a general election
and my belief is that heavy sticks to
the kind of
progressive ambitious um alternatives
that
have been developed under labour over
the last uh of five years then i think
he will be
our prime minister and if he doesn't i
think he'll be in trump
okay uh the polling may not necessarily
uh agree with you
um because it does feel as if labour is
doing pretty well under
uh kirsten much better than uh the state
of the party uh
that he uh was inherited from jeremy
corbyn so here is the latest
hugo paul september 16th and 17th labour
and the conservatives both
on 40 now two days before jeremy corbyn
stepped down as labour
as leader sorry label was on 28 that's
24 points behind
some people would say looking at the
polls he's doing all the right things to
distance himself
i think that's a well i don't know about
distancing himself from corbyn
i i thought you asked him an interesting
question about brexit
the reality of course is labor lost the
lack of last election on one issue only
and that was brexit
the conservatives formed the government
with 44 percent
extraordinary on one slogan get brexit
done
now that's why kia very cleverly is
sidestepping
the prime minister's trap to pull him
back into brexit because brexit would be
divisive
in the labour party brexit needs to be
out of the way and i think then what
you'll see if you check back with your
research is on some of the previous
polls
what policies cobin put forward on a
whole range of issues
were very popular with with the public
in particular in our red wall seats so
that's what kia has to do he's trying to
navigate his way
through a difficult situation and i want
to help him those on the left want to
help him
but he said he's listening to people
around the country which he is
and he needs to listen to the left
because without the left
uh within our movement then kia will
i'm afraid sail the ship onto the rocks
and
i don't think he'll do that i think he's
up for listening
and the unity that he looks for is
important in his pledge when he ran for
leader he said
he intended to make the moral case for
socialism
that will do me if he continues that
line okay uh len mccluskey thank you
very much always interesting to talk
thank you